>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, FIRST
LADY, WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
MISTER PRESIDENT, IT HAS BEEN
NEARLY NINE MONTHS OF THIS WAR,
NOW DO YOU EXPECT IT TO LAST
THIS, LONG GIVEN A IDEA ABOUT
HOW LONG IT MIGHT LAST?
>> THANK YOU FOR THE.
QUESTION AND THANK YOU FOR THE
MONITORING.
SHE ASKS WHETHER I THOUGHT THIS
WAR WOULD LAST.
NO, I DIDN'T START THIS WAR,
I'M SURE THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
UKRAINIAN WHO KNEW WHAT THIS
WILL BE.
AND WHAT TRAGEDY THIS WOULD
BRING TO EVERY HOME IN OUR
COUNTRY.
BECAUSE, I REPEAT, WE DID NOT
START THIS WAR.
BUT UKRAINIAN SOCIETY UNITED,
AND SHOWED THAT IT WAS READY
FOR WHAT, UNFORTUNATELY, WAS
SUCH A TRAGEDY.
SHOWING THAT IT WAS READY FOR
THESE CHALLENGES.
I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED BY THE
POWER OF ONE NATION.
AND WAS IMPRESSED BY THE
SWIFTNESS OF THE RESPONSE OF
EUROPE.
THE WHOLE WORLD.
AND THE WHOLE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY THAT RALLIED AROUND
UKRAINE.
FOR THIS CHALLENGE.
>> FIRST LADY, WHAT MOTIVATED
YOU TO GET UP IN THE MORNING?
HOW DO YOU FEEL THAT YOU HAVE
ENDURED THIS WAR?
>> WELL, THANK.
YOU IT IS A BIG QUESTION.
IT COVERS MANY SPHERES OF MY
LIFE.
AND WHAT HELPS ME GET UP IN THE
MORNING, SHORTLY AS YOU SAID,
IS MY HUSBAND'S EXAMPLE.
I KNOW THAT IF HE, ENDURES THAN
I HAVE TO ENDURE.
IF THE DAY HAS BEGUN, THEN WE
HAVE TO KEEP FIGHTING.
THAT KEEPS ME GOING.
IT'S NOT EASY EVERY DAY, BUT
YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO KEEP
RUNNING.
YOU CANNOT STOP.
AS --
SO YOU HAVE TO RUN EVEN FASTER.
THAT IS WHY WE RUN.
WE GET SOME INSPIRATION FROM
THE, KIDS FROM THE CHILDREN.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THERE ARE
SOME ORDINARY THINGS THAT EVERY
FAMILY IS DOING.
YOU NEED TO GET YOUR SON READY
FOR SCHOOL, NEED TO MAKE SURE
YOUR SOME BREAKFAST.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE INSURANCE
THAT MY CHILD WILL GO TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY, BECAUSE OF THOSE
STRIKES WITH MISSILES AND
DRONES.
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK.
A LOT OF HUMAN PROJECTS THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE AFTER THE WAR.
THAT HELPS A LOT.
>> I WANTED TO ASK YOU HOW YOU
REACT.
YOU WILL MONITOR RUSSIAN
CASUALTIES AND ACTIVITY ON THE
UKRAINIAN BATTLEFIELD.
AND THE PENTAGON ACTUALLY IS
VERY INDEFENSIBLY SAT AND I'M
GOING TO QUOTE TO GET IT RIGHT,
RUSSIA HAS PROBABLY LOST HALF
OF ITS MAIN BATTLE PLANKS, USED
UP MOST OF ITS PRECISION GUIDED
WEAPONS IN THIS WAR, THE 80% OF
THEIR LAND FORCES BOGGED DOWN,
HERE.
IT IS, STOP HERE, AND UKRAINE.
DOES THAT MATCH YOUR FIGURES,
AND WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER TO THAT?
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> >> TRANSLATOR: I THINK THIS
MORE LESS CORRESPONDS TO
REALITY.
ALTHOUGH, FRANKLY.
SPEAKING NOBODY KNOWS THE FULL
REALITY.
ESPECIALLY AS REGARDS
PERSONNEL.
NOBODY CAN TELL YOU PRECISELY
HOW MANY PEOPLE DIED.
NEVERTHELESS, WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ARTILLERY THAT WAS
PROVIDED HAS ASSISTANCE TO US
FOR THE UNITED STATES AND
EUROPE.
DEFINITELY HAD TO BREAK THIS
INITIATIVE WHICH RUSSIAN
LAUNCHED ON THE 24TH OF
FEBRUARY.
--
THIS MILITARY INITIATIVE, WHICH
STOP.
THEN OCCUPIED A LARGE PART OF
THE TERRITORY.
AND, THIS INDEED, WAS HELPED BY
THE ARTILLERY.
AND THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
WE NEVER RESORTED TO ANY OF THE
LINES THAT THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION PRODUCES, LIKE BONDS
OR NUCLEAR CHALLENGES AND SO
ON.
I AM VERY PLEASED THAT WE ARE
WORKING JOINTLY.
AND RESPONDING QUICKLY TO THAT.
STRAIGHT AFTER RUSSIA'S
ALLEGATIONS WE INVITED THE IEA.
AND THEY VERIFIED EVERYTHING
AND SAID IT IS JUST ANOTHER LIE
FROM RUSSIA.
SO I CANNOT CONFIRM FOR SURE,
BUT I CAN SAY FOR SURE THAT IT
IS A STUNNING NUMBER BOTH IN
TERMS OF HEAVY WEAPONS AND
PERSONNEL.
>> THEIR LOSS IS HEAVIER THAN
YOUR LOSSES?
>> YES.
TEN TIMES.
I THINK, SO APPROXIMATELY.
I CAN'T GIVE YOU THE EXACT
NUMBERS.
IT IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE.
OUR WAR TACTIC IS NOT TO THROW
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE MOST
IMPORTANT.
NOT USING PEOPLE AS CANNON
FODDER.
THAT IS WHY IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US.
WHENEVER WE ASKED OUR PARTNERS
FOR ARTILLERY OR ARMORED
VEHICLES, THAT IT IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE WEAPONS BUT FIRST OF
ALL PROTECTION FOR OUR
MILITARY.
>> MADAM FIRST LADY, YOU JUST
RETURNED FROM A MAJOR TECH
CONFERENCE.
I THINK THE WORLD HAS NOTED
THAT UKRAINE HAS USED
TECHNOLOGY IN A REALLY
INNOVATIVE AN EFFECTIVE WAY.
WHAT WAS YOUR MESSAGE THERE AND
WHAT YOU WANT THE TEMPORAL TO
DO FOR THIS COUNTRY?
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> >> TRANSLATOR: MY MESSAGE
WAS PRETTY SIMPLE I HOPE IT WAS
A HERD.
PEOPLE GATHERED THERE WERE
PEOPLE --
TO FALL.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE AN IMPACT ON
WHICH DIRECTION TECHNOLOGY IN
THE WHOLE WORLD WILL MOVE IN
THE FUTURE.
MY APPEAL TO THEM IS TO CHOOSE
A SIDE.
WHAT TECHNOLOGY THEY WILL
INVENT OR DESIGN.
WILL THIS BE A TECHNOLOGY THAT
KILLS, OR IN TECHNOLOGY THAT
DEFENDS?
BECAUSE WE HAVE A WONDERFUL
EXAMPLE, FOR EXAMPLE --
RECENTLY CONDUCTED THEIR LATEST
INVESTIGATION.
AND THEY FOUND THAT THE GROUP
OF I.T. EXPERTS FROM RUSSIA,
YOUNG PEOPLE AGED 20 3:25,
BEFORE THE WAR THEY WORKED IN
PRIVATE 90 COMPANIES.
NOW THEY ARE TARGETING MISSILES
AND BUILDINGS.
THIS IS A CHOICE.
A CONSCIOUS CHOICE MADE BY
PEOPLE WHO KNOW THIS TECHNOLOGY,
WHO HAVE THE EXPERTISE.
NARROW SPECIALISTS.
THEY CHOSE TO BE MURDERERS AND
TERRORISTS.
MY APPEAL TO ALL THOSE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE GATHERED AT
THE SUMMIT WAS TO MAKE THE
CHOICE FROM A MORAL AND ETHICAL
STANDPOINT.
AS TO WHAT THEY WILL DO IN THE
FUTURE.
AND, REALLY THESE ANALOGIES
HELP.
>> WHAT IS THE STATUS OF
KHERSON AND THE IMPENDING
BATTLE TO RETAKE KHERSON?
>> TRANSLATOR: THERE IS A VERY
SERIOUS QUESTION.
AND I WILL BE FRANK WITH.
YOU I WILL TRY TO ANSWER IT IN
THE WAY THAT DOES NOT GIVE YOU
AN ANSWER, TO BE HONEST.
BECAUSE THESE PLANNED MILITARY
ACTIONS, THEY ARE DISCUSSED IN
A SMALL CIRCLE.
BUT THEN THEY ARE EXECUTED IN
SILENCE.
AND I REALLY WANT TO HAVE --
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE AN
UNPLEASANT SURPRISE FOR THE,
ENEMY AND NOT SOMETHING THEY
ARE PREPARED.
FOR SO I WOULD LIKE TO
APOLOGIZE.
BUT AT ANY RATE, OUR PEOPLE AND
YOUR PUBLIC NEEDS TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON SOME VERY
SERIOUS STEPS, WITH A POSITIVE
OUTCOME FOR THE CITIZENS OF
UKRAINE.
AND FOR ALL THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT SUPPORT PEACE AND UKRAINE.
>> THE RUSSIANS ARE OBSERVED AS
DIGGING IN THE VERY VERY HARD,
SOME 3 TO 4 LAYERS.
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE SOUTH,
TO THE PORT.
TO THE SEA.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
MOUNTING A MORE SERIOUS DEFENSE
OF KHERSON THEN PERHAPS THE
OTHER AREAS THAT YOU HAVE
LIBERATED?
>> >> TRANSLATOR: THAT IS
RIGHT.
THEY WERE VERY POWERFUL
DEFENSE.
AND NOT WHAT WE MEAN ABOUT THE
MILITARY HEADQUARTERS, WE MET
AND AT FIRST WE CANNOT BELIEVE
THAT THEY WOULD BE RUNNING AWAY
FROM HOUSE ON.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS WAR IS JUST
AN ATTEMPT TO DRAW MORE
UKRAINIAN TROOPS IN THAT
DIRECTION.
>> WE'VE HEARD OF MANY
UKRAINIAN CHILDREN BEING TAKEN
OVER TO RUSSIA.
WE DO NOT, NOW IT REALLY, WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
HERE IN KYIV AND IN THE AREA.
I HAVE MET AND WATCHED OVER THE
LAST FEW DAYS.
GOOD TO HAVE OBVIOUSLY BEEN
TRAUMATIZED BY THE WAR, AERATE
SIREN, FRIGHTENING LITTLE ONES.
KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN TOLD TO BE
QUIET AND HIDE QUIETLY.
I'M DIFFICULTY SPEAKING AND
COMMUNICATING.
SOME KIDS HAVE SEEN HORRIBLE
THINGS HAPPEN UNDER OCCUPATION.
THEIR MOTHERS, RAPED FOR
INSTANCE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE A MOTHER, BUT
YOU ARE VERY INVOLVED IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH ASPECT.
AND WITH YOUR FOUNDATION AS,
WELL WITH WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
>> TRANSLATOR: FIRST OF ALL IT
IS A BIG TRAGEDY THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE BEING TAKEN AWAY
TO RUSSIA.
THERE IS A LARGE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE SOCIAL
SERVICES LOST CONNECTION WITH,
SO WE CANNOT FIND THEM.
SOMETHING THE, SUMMER RUSSIANS
RELAX THEIR ADOPTION
LEGISLATION.
THEY SIMPLIFIED THE PROCEDURE
TO ADOPT UKRAINIAN CHILDREN,
WHICH IS HORRIBLE.
AND WE UNDERSTAND WE WILL HAVE
TO FIGHT FOR THEM.
AND WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT AT
ALL INTERNATIONAL FORUMS.
CURRENTLY, WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT
ON THE EVACUATION OF TWO
CHILDREN'S HOMES FROM THE
ODESSA REGION.
AND THIS IS ALREADY AN
AGREEMENT REACHED WITH TURKEY.
WE ARE TRYING TO SAVE THEM IN
ADVANCE.
BUT JUST TWO DAYS AGO, I HAD
NEWS THAT A CHILDREN'S HOME AS
WE MOVE FROM THE OCCUPIED
TERRITORIES IN THE KHERSON
REGION.
WE CANNOT REACH, THEM
UNFORTUNATELY.
WE CANNOT SAVE THEM.
BUT HOPEFULLY THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY WILL HELP US RETURN
OUR CHILDREN.
NOW, AS REGARDS HELPING THOSE
CHILDREN WHO SUFFER
PSYCHOLOGICALLY FROM THE
HORRORS OF WAR, NOW THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THESE CHILDREN
ALREADY.
WE CANNOT EVEN IMAGINE WHAT
THOSE CHILDREN SUFFERED.
WHO HAD TO BURY THEIR OWN
MOTHER IN THE HEARTS OF THEIR
HOME.
OR SAW THEIR RELATIVES
MURDERED.
WHO STAYED IN THE BASEMENT OF
MARIUPOL.
WE CAN ONLY OBSERVE THEM A TRY
TO HELP.
AND FOR THAT PURPOSE, WE ARE
ESTABLISHING A NATIONAL PROGRAM
ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
PSYCHOSOCIAL SUPPORTS.
WHICH I HOPE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
PROJECTS.
I CAN GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
, ONCE FAIRLY SUCCESSFUL I
BELIEVE, WELL ORGANIZED THE
COUNTS TOGETHER WITH UKRAINIAN
PSYCHOLOGIST AND DONORS.
THERE WERE 20 KIDS WITH
PSYCHOLOGICAL ISSUES.
WE TOOK THEM TO A SPECIAL CAMP
WHERE THE SHOOTERS WERE
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
WE SPENT 20 DAYS IN SPAIN UNDER
CONSTANT 24-HOUR PSYCHOLOGICAL
MONITORING.
AND THIS THERAPY HAD WONDERFUL
RESULTS.
THE CHILDREN WHO DID NOT SPEAK
STARTED SPEAKING, THE CHILDREN
WHO AREN'T EATING DISORDERS OR
DIDN'T EAT AT ALL, THERE WAS
ONE WHO NEVER SLEPT.
THE TEACHERS HAD TO SLEEP
BESIDE THEM, BECAUSE YOU CAN
ONLY SPEAK IF THERE WERE
SOMEBODY NEXT TO HIM.
AND, INDEED WE SAW WONDERFUL
RESULTS.
WE WANT TO SCALE UP THIS
PROJECT.
WE ARE SUPPORTED BY EXPERTS
FROM ISRAEL AND BELGIUM.
THE NEXT TRAINING DESTINATION
FOR OUR SPECIALIST WILL BE IN
THE UK.
VERY SOON THIS MONTH WE WILL BE
SENDING A PSYCHOLOGIST AND
PSYCHOTHERAPIST FOR TRAINING
THERE.
WHICH IS THE WORLD'S BEST
PRACTICES EVER COPING WITH
PTSD.